il continue à traverser le fleuve avec
leur vie sur leurs épaules la rangée de
voitures au loin du gouverneur texan ne
fait rien pour les dissuader rejetée par
tous et venant d'un pays exemple ces
réfugiés sont devenus les damnés de la
terre du 21e siècle ils seraient environ
cinq mille haïtiens la frontière la
situation est sous contrôle dit le
département de la sécurité intérieure
est désormais des patrouilles à cheval
sont interdites temporairement
depuis dimanche plus de 3000 personnes
ont été acceptés dans le pays et en
quatre jours 1400 haïtiens ont déjà été
renvoyés en haïti
édité verne vient d'être déportés
on nous a d'abord enchaîné en prison dit
il puis on nous a emmenés à l'aéroport
on nous a dit de ne pas résister tv
plusieurs militaires à bord de l'avion
la question que je pose aux douaniers
dit il est-ce qu'ils ont du travail pour
tous les haïtiens qu'ils ont déporté
kidnapping prise d'otage violence des
gangs de rue l'envoyé spécial américain
daniel foot n'a pas mâché ses mots dans
sa lettre de démission il écrit qu'il ne
veut pas être associée à un gouvernement
qui agit de façon inhumaine en renvoyant
les haïtiens dans un pays qui fait déjà
face à une crise humanitaire
le traitement des migrants haïtiens la
frontière du mexique ravive les tensions
raciales
se moque de ce qu'on a vu à la frontière
nous ramène alias entendra-t-elle des
cowboys fouettant des personnes noires
avec un lasso ces réfugiés ne font que
sur la violence dans leurs pires skype
à la frontière alléluia espère aider les
siens né en haïti vit aux états unis
depuis 22 ans il a conduit 20 heures
pour se rendre à la frontière pour
apporter des sandwichs aux migrants de
l'autre côté
ma famille a fui haïti à 20 ans dit il
j'ai bénéficié de cette migration
de voir que désaisi ont été fouettés ça
me fait mal dit il ils sont ma famille
et je veux les aider les vols vers haïti
continue tous les jours depuis dimanche
il y en a eu 12 vers port-au-prince et
cap haïtien des réfugiés haïtiens qui
voulait une vie meilleure ici aux
etats-unis qui se retrouvent dans un
pays démuni ou personne peut assurer
leur sécurité ici à deux pas de la gare
qui sera du canada del rio texas